we are learning more about the case of
the four students murdered near the
University of Idaho and the more you
hear the worse it gets yesterday a judge
unsealed the investigator's search
warrant for suspect Brian coburger and
it included details of what they say
that they found at his home Lilia
Luciana joins us now with the latest on
this story Lily good morning to you good
morning Gail well the unsealed warrant
reveals how police established probable
cause to search coverger's apartment and
importantly what they recovered from it
the documents present geolocation
evidence from what investigators believe
to be co-burger's phone after the
killings alleging quote it is likely
that he still had blood or other trace
evidence on his body when he returned
home and quote likely that some trace
evidence was transferred to areas in his
apartment as a result police say the
list of items seized from coburger's
apartment in Pullman Washington includes
a nitrite type black glove eight
possible hair strands a computer tower
collection of a dark red spot we don't
know exactly which item that was it
wasn't specified plus cuttings of a
reddish brown stain from an uncased
pillow and two mattress covers with
multiple stains we don't know what those
samples reveal at this time of course we
hope to learn later in a trial and
police haven't released a potential
motive for the killings of those four
University of Idaho students in November
coburger is a due back in court for a
preliminary hearing on June 26th as we
know we has not he has not entered a
plea but if found guilty he could face
life in prison or the death penalty
all right Lilia thank you very much